[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission vais y
paix avec mon invité anne weber bonjour
bonjour vous êtes la fondatrice d'une
entreprise de conseil d'entreprise
plutôt qui s'appelle lienemann we just
bon on croit dans les dents les qualités
humaines est dans l'humain c'est ça
c'est ce que ça veut dire et vous êtes
aussi de l'autriche d'un d'un livre qui
s'appelle powerful procrastination et on
va parler avec vous de ce mot un peu
étrange mais fin qui est de plus en plus
employée je crois que c'était le mot le
plus recherché en 2020 sur google c'est
ça la procrastination pourquoi on va en
parler d'abord parce qu'ils journée
internationale de la procrastination qui
a lieu le 25 mars
c'est bizarre qui est une journée
m'intéresse à deux prosternations nantes
d'où ça vient ça c'est un grand
procrastinateurs qui a souhaité je pense
réhabiliter cette notion qu'on revienne
à quelque chose de plus positif et qui
du coup a proposé sa création lisa
preuve d'aucun ville en fait il a fait
un petit livre une sorte de petite
collection de mots autour de la
procrastination et on lui doit cette
journée depuis une dizaine d'années
maintenant je crois alors on va parler
de ce que c'est la procrastination et il
ya un lien évidemment avec votre métier
de conseil d'entreprise c'est que vous
allez nous expliquer pourquoi ça peut
servir dans les autres fenêtres
procrastinateurs pour la sénatrice
alors d'abord
il faut il faut définir d'abord ce que
c'est la procrastination c'est il ya un
proverbe qui dit ne remet jamais à
demain ce que tu peux faire le jour même
et le procrastinateur dibassy moi je
remet à demain ce que je pourrais faire
le jour même c'est ça oui la
procrastination ce qui est intéressant
d'avoir en tête c'est que au moyen âge
c'était un mot qui t'a permis au
moyen-âge et un mot plutôt positif en
fait quand on procrastine st1 marc et
c'était quelque chose qui était très
différent de la fainéantise donc au
départ il ya eu des grands
procrastinateurs on retrouve mozart
léonard de vinci
grands artistes de grands artistes et
pour les grands curieux qui comment dire
nous écouterait il ya un documentaire
une mini série d'arte et ce bruit
respiration qui va redonner en fait un
petit peu ses clés et puis au fur et à
mesure ça c'est est libre ces déchets
les mots à nax c'est arrivé au xvème
siècle un sceau cette affaire et puis ça
a glissé et à l'époque actuelle dans la
définition par exemple du larousse on
dit tendance pathologique à différer de
l'ordre de la maladie pour ceux qui sont
sur linkedin le cours sur linkedin par
exemple est très négatif et parle aussi
de pathologies alors pour nous faire des
beaux indécision ajournement paraissent
1 c'est ce qui vient quand on parle de
progression et c'est vrai que là on est
pas très bien quand est ce dire j'aurais
dû le faire aujourd'hui alors tant pis
je le ferai demain mais un c'est bien le
côté phénomène on
va devoir les procrastinateurs sont
peut-être des feignants sublime et c'est
intéressant alors le premier sujet c'est
ce qu'est la procrastination est ce
qu'elle n'est pas souvent on a tendance
en fait à mélanger ce mot avec d'autres
notions c'est important de faire cette
différence parce que si on pose pas le
bon mot on n'aura pas la bonne solution
très souvent c'est confondu avec le
premier sujet ce qu'on peut qualifier de
capitaux logis c'est à dire quand on est
pendant des heures sur twitter ou sur
les réseaux sociaux on est vraiment dans
un mécanisme qui entretenu on appelle ça
la science de la captation d'attention
tout est fait pour nous entraîner
finalement à le faire donc ça c'est une
notion intéressante mais c'est pas de la
procrastination par exemple non ce que
voulait est ce que cette barre dont un
bébé si on est c'est notre attention et
capté par autre chose on peut passer des
heures sur les réseaux sociaux et ne pas
faire ce qu'on avait à faire il ya aussi
non eh bien nous ce que l'on recommandé
ce qui est bien précis dans le petit
livre c'est de comprendre ce mécanisme
qui ne va pas être de la procrastination
qui est vraiment être attentif aux
mécanismes qui nous rendent captif des
réseaux sociaux il ya un livre qui a été
écrit par exemple par bruno patino qui
est vraiment là alors je sais plus
exactement il ya mon poisson rouge dans
le titre je leur site dans l'ouvragé qui
est très bien très pédagogique très
sympa à lire il explique bien ce
phénomène et puis du coup une personne
averti en valant deux c'est beaucoup
plus simple de s'en détacher deuxième
élément souvent on confond finalement
également la procrastination avec une
moindre capacité à se concentrer on est
dans une société où finalement notre
capacité de concentration et souvent
battue en brèche et là c'est difficile
est pareil ce n'est pas de la
procrastination et il est mieux comment
dire plus utile de retravailler sa
capacité à se concentrer
on le voit notamment sur des
consommations un peu importante d'écran
chez les enfants les études pour peu
qu'on regarde de façon très précise
montre bien que l'on va avoir une
concentration qui va baisser
hélas pour les grands curieux allez voir
les travaux de des murs j'ai qui est un
neuroscientifique sur par exemple la
fabrique du crétin digital qui va
vraiment bien expliciter ses mécanismes
ou comment la tension peut descendre
je fais le trajet troisième exception
qu'il faut enlever on peut aussi avoir
des vraies blessures psychologiques des
vrais sujets un événement comment dire
de mémoire traumatique un viol une
grande difficulté et avoir un
difficultés à passer à l'acte là non
plus ne sera pas de la procrastination
une fois qu'on a enlevé ses trois sujets
mais c'est quoi la procrastination c'est
la capacité à calculer des scénarios
dans des environnements complexes on a
partagé avec vous une petite
conversation et à calculer des scénarios
dans des environnements complexes on l'a
représenté dans le livre avec une
métaphore visuelle un hélicoptère au
dessus d'un labyrinthe et avec une
flèche qui traverse le labyrinthe
pourquoi c'est parce que le
procrastinateur a un talent spécifique
que tout le monde n'a pas est-ce que je
vais raconter ne parlera peut-être qu'à
une partie de vos zones it heures qui va
être de comprendre la complexité ou l'a
symbolisé par le labyrinthe plus fort il
n'en est que d'autres je comprend ce qui
se passe ceux qui n'ont pas ce talent
basson dans le labyrinthe et vont avoir
le nez sur le mur ont trouvé ça moins
facile et ils vont vendre la capacité à
calculer la meilleure façon de procéder
pourquoi du coup on a ces sujets de
délai et bien c'est parce que tant que
tous les éléments ne sont pas présents
dans le calcul on pourrait avoir un
meilleur scénario donc tant que je n'ai
pas de deadline la peine de lancer ce
supercalculateur
cepandant j'essaye de deux groupes au
savoir si j'ai à peu compris est ce que
ça veut dire qu'au fond le progrès
serait une trés nateur procrastinateurs
où la progression matrix ce sont des
gens qui réfléchissent longuement à la
solution du problème et qui ne
l'appliqué cop10 soit à peu près sûr
qu'elle est bonne non celle inverse ah
c'est que on pourrait pour les fans
d'harry potter on voit qu'on peut avoir
des photos qui bouge ou les gens qui ont
vu ce film labyrinthe ce labyrinthe il
pourrait bouger on pourrait le faire
animer il y a toujours des nouveaux
éléments quand on est dans une situation
complexe il y a toujours de nouveaux
éléments qui vont venir dans le calcul
dans la prise en compte donc le
procrastinateur s'il n'a pas de deadline
s'il n'est pas obligé de calculer il va
naturellement attendre le lendemain et
puis le lendemain et puis le lendemain
puisqu'il pourrait y avoir de nouveaux
éléments dans cette situation complexe
juste ce n'est pas juste cette
association on retrouve par exemple dans
les gestions de crise sur des nôtres
d'opérations dans des gestions de crise
des procrastinateurs qui font merveille
on en a parmi nos clients pourquoi c'est
parce que là ils sont deadline d'après
deadline et du coup on a vraiment
l'essence même de ce talent le calcul de
scénarios dans des environnements
extrêmement complexe donc il faut se
défaire
de line beauvau m il faut des deadlines
ses clés pour les procrastinateurs et
idéalement des deadlines générés par
d'autres un exemple vous faire rire
quand j'ai décidé d'écrire le livre je
suis moi même une grande
procrastinatrice j'ai commencé par
donner une deadline en dix ans ce sera
sorti le jour
de la journée mondiale la
procrastination jeu les annoncer à tout
le monde et ensuite je me suis mise à
écrire le livre j'étais bloqué il
fallait que ce soit sorti on est vrai
que ça oui il ya ya ya aussi le est ce
que le fait de par exemple de se mettre
au dernier moment faire quelque chose
c'est de la procrastination clairement
coeur dans tous les procrastinateurs se
met toujours systématiquement à la
dernière mais toujours dans cette
logique d'avoir l'ensemble des éléments
on a toujours quatre grandes phrases de
la procrastination que l'on va répéter
inlassablement elles sont décrites dans
le livre quand on n'a pas conscience de
ces phases on peut un peu les subir on
peut se dire à certains moments mais je
ne comprends rien je suis bête je
n'arrive pas à avancer on peut se dire à
certains moments j'ai le cerveau
encombré mon dieu ça n'est pas clair et
puis ensuite à voir ces deux moments de
fulgurance où on va pouvoir enfin
délivré comprendre toutes ces étapes ce
qui se passe cérébralement c'est la
possibilité de les maîtriser et de ne
garder que le bon côté des choses mais
je reviens ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure vous avez vous disiez non mais
je crois que c'est quand même un peu
élevé des cds que le procrastinateur
c'est pas celui qui réfléchit
la solution du problème assez longuement
et donc y re et qui repousse le moment
de le résoudre au moment où il est sûr
de livres résonance non
parce que tout faux quand je dis ça
ce que je veux dire c'est que souvent on
attache à la procrastination
le fait de ne pas être sûr d'avoir une
mésestime de soi et donc on a pondu
quelques bonnes décisions on a posé
quelque chose d'assez faut souvent des
progrès sinon comment dire sévères comme
moi peuvent avoir à stoner
procrastinateurs progressé tant pour
l'heure les deux on peut dire les deux
vont parfois à voir ce syndrome de
l'imposteur parce que à certains moments
donnés dans leur vie ils auront eu
l'impression d'avoir été bête sur
certains sujets en fait pour que le
cerveau d'un procrastinateurs fonctionne
bien il a besoin d'avoir un peu les
coins du labyrinthe dans quel bac à
sable ou de complexité je vais jouer ça
vient très vite ensuite mais ces moments
on a pu se sentir un peu perdus quand on
n'a pas compris comment ça marche
peuvent donner un peu ce syndrome de
l'imposteur comme on l'entend parfois on
fait donc on commence par les or on
décrit tout ça dans le livre on donne un
petit peu tous les conseils a quand même
une pression sociale est contre la
procrastination à ses portes alors il
est quand on a compris ça en fait
honnêtement quand on l'a compris on
accompagne des entreprises à tous
niveaux on a eu des lecteurs de vraiment
à des niveaux ex comme très élevé il n'y
a pas de sujet en fait parce que quand
on a compris comment ça fonctionne on ne
perd pas son temps à culpabiliser on
travaille à bonne escient au bon moment
s'il faut on fixe des deadline
successives pour remettre l'ouvragé
comment dire sur sur le garrot il n'y a
pas de sujet en fait alors pas alors un
peu du travail de ce que vous faites
dans une meinau et clust c'est dire
chercher au fond dans les entreprises
les talents humains et donc peut-être
convaincre parfois des de l'encadrement
que ce qu'on prend pour des défauts la
procrastination est un phare mais
d'autres ça peut être des qualités c'est
après ça tout à fait en fait on part
vraiment le management classique et du
coup on est prétentieux petits visuels
classique c'est quoi ou l' approche
classique que ce soit dans une école que
je vais leur en entreprise on va le
retrouver dans la partie grise et on va
prendre un individu vous moi l'élève
dont vous me parliez tout à l'heure un
manager un leader et on va le comparer à
la personne parfaite dans le même rôle
donc le leader va être comparé au leader
parfait steve jobs qui monte sur scène
qui inspire enquête fait une idée dans
son garage vous allez être comparés
peut-être au présentateur vedette
comment dire de tf1 et moi je vais être
comparée à la femme parfaite avec de
longues jambes etc les leaders en ce
moment la grande mode par exemple c'est
les leaders doivent être empathique donc
on va comparer notre leader réel avec le
leader parfait et on va déterminer des
zones de moindres performances
symbolisée ici par seront et ses zones
intermédiaires
dans l'acception plaisent classique on
va investir là où on n'est pas bon
le leader qui n'est pas bon et qui n'est
pas empathique quoi on va corriger on va
lui offrir une formation d'empathie le
leader qui ne souhaitent pas monter sur
scène parce qu'il ya un peu timide et
n'est pas bon en prise de parole en
public on a cette idée que le doyen
donc on va investir de sucer des as qui
a symbolisé par sa deuxième étoile on va
investir sur ces zones moindre
performance de haut en bas tout à fait
la deuxième on va en fait investir pour
se détendre dans un noir et puis on va
essayer lui demander d'être moins donc
si on à votre élève de tout à l'heure
qui est trop en retard ou trop énergique
par exemple on a des élèves et
bien on leur demandera d'être moins
actifs le management par les talents
prend complètement le contre-pied si un
courant qui est né aux etats-unis à la
fin du siècle dernier j'ai eu la chance
de le rencontrer à ce moment là parce
que je souhaitais absolument comprendre
comment on peut remettre cette unicité
humaine au coeur de l'entreprise et là
on va juste identifier ce que les gens
font naturellement bien on ne regarde
pas de notion de perfection va plutôt
viser l'excellence dont il ya une notion
d'effort mais vraiment pour viser
l'excellence et on va investir sur ses
talents naturels jusqu'à ce que les gens
puissent les maîtriser on al'exemple la
de la procrastination jusqu'à ce que les
délais ne soit plus un sujet et jusqu'à
ce que les gens puissent vraiment garder
ce qui est clé de dans la lecture de la
complexité pour le faire dans tous types
de sujets par talent naturel humain on
va parler derrière d'anticipation des
risques de lecture du futur d'analystes
de l'histoire
de sensibilité énormément de talent très
simple ça marche dans les entreprises
est en train de révolutionner un peu
lors celle du mans pendant longtemps
voilà il y avait un seul enseignement
pour pour tous et là on est en train
d'autres dont certains avec les cités ce
qu'est la cité éducative notamment à de
favoriser bel étalon l'état lors des
deux enfants dit donc c'est en effet une
autre manière de voir le monde 2 et aux
faux de se dire que chacun a un talent
en inde et à un talon saison la bonne
nouvelle c'est que nous avons tous des
talents autres de mal en pis naizin
unique de talent et avec l'outil par
exemple américain qu'on utilise vous
avez une chance sur
470 mille milliards de rencontrer
quelqu'un qui a les mêmes talents actifs
au quotidien une chanson sur 470 mille
milliards de rencontrer quelqu'un qui
aime on aime tous naturels on est tous
absolument unique et de l'avs en fait
énormément d'incompréhension puisque
c'est unicité week tout l'enjeu du
management par les talents tel qu'on le
pratique c'est de réconcilier ces
unicité pour que chacun puisse mieux se
comprendre et mieux interagir avec les
autres alors votre votre votre boîte
s'appelle une maîtresse vous êtes à
paris et à versailles j'avais oublié de
dire des gours vous présentez vous avez
aussi dirigé pendant quelques noms
posséder la culture au département de
des yvelines et puis rappelez moi l'ailé
mais grands noms là de beaux-arts de
programmeurs victor hugo donc on va les
retrouver de façon de façon l'argent
fait procrastine vous tous merci
beaucoup albert
[Musique]